how are you feeling in the aftermath of
Peter
Hitchens validated
Vindicated uh I must say that I was a
little
bit I was in two minds about uploading
that that interview he does there was a
bit of a a mixture of opinion coming
from him he wasn't speaking entirely
clearly must have been something on his
mind he said as he's getting up to walk
out I don't think you should run this
and I'm thinking look if if if my guest
tells me that they don't want to run an
interview for any reason it could be
because they've had a bad hair day then
I'll respect that and so I thought damn
am I really going to have to you know be
the big a man here and just not post
this at all but then he kept saying oh
run it if you like I can't stop you from
running it I just don't think you have
any moral right to run it and I asked
him why and he said it was because I'm a
propagandist for drug decriminalization
a subject which prior to that by the way
I'd spoken about once
ever and that I'd intentionally tricked
him to appear on my podcast in order
that I might fool him into a
conversation about drugs now before the
podcast started I said Mr Hitchens you
have uh about three subject areas that
we both talk about where I think there's
a bit of crossover that you've either
spoken about or indeed written books
about and those are the
decriminalization of drugs I also
mentioned this in my email the existence
of God or religion I should say God and
religion is the topic and uh the third
was monarchy at this point he says well
you know monarchy is a bit
boring okay notice listener that he did
not take this opportunity to tell me
that he thought that drugs were a bit
boring and we rather not really talk
about drugs at all or for too long okay
fine so I'm thinking I agree with you
the monarchy is incredibly boring in
fact that's the entirety of my point
about the monarchy is that it's
essentially just boring more than
anything else so let's just do the other
two so I say it will run for about an
hour ideally he says that's good you
know and I say but you know if the
conversation flows it can be an hour and
a half it could be 2 hours
and okay he says well look you know I
say sometimes they can be 3 hours long
he says well 3 hours might be a bit long
but we'll see how we do something in
about an hour and a half an hour and a
half on what was now in my view two
subjects so at about 40 minutes into
this potentially 90-minute podcast on
the same topic when he told me that
we've been going around for too long on
said topic I was a little bit bemused
but I did think to myself maybe I've
done something wrong here maybe I have
upset him in a way that obviously was
not intentional you know I wasn't trying
to bring this out of him although you
know it does do quite well for the
channel it's not like it's something I
would do intentionally so I did think to
myself well maybe I've done something so
I listened back and I sent it to some
friends including you and thank you for
listening to it and and saying that like
most people just said you have to run
this he's he's been completely
unreasonable and so there have been
criticisms people have said well you
know what it was a bit boring or yeah it
was going around in circles I submit
that that was his fault by the way uh
because
he does this thing which I've noticed in
a lot of philosophical and political
discussion uh which is the sort of I
know this one attitude when you do a lot
of interviews I find that you have a
sort of I know this one and so they
answer the question that they heard not
the answer that was asked exactly and
and it and it
happens especially when it's it's easy
enough to make that mistake if you're
not listening carefully so he was
talking about uh the well I I asked him
about the decriminalization of of of
cannabis and he says that well this will
essentially mean that a lot of more
children will be smoking it he he had
this contention that children would end
up smoking cannabis and I thought to
myself well okay I can understand that
concern of course but I think the
tobacco industry has suffered quite a
blow in still being perfectly legal to
buy as an adult but but kids just aren't
smoking cigarettes anymore it's just not
a thing that's really done why is that
in other words we've had quite a
successful education campaign whereby
it's not popular for kids to smoke
anymore and yet it's still perfectly
legal can't we have a similar approach
to cannabis potentially by the way not a
good view potentially a perfectly
rebuttable view I'm not sure but I
wouldn't know because I didn't get a
rebuttal to that view instead I just
heard you know all you can do is is do
the whole which by the way is a
genuinely quite tired line in this
debate the whole oh what about smoking
or indeed another point where I brought
up alcohol well all you can say is what
about alcohol what about
smoking and that's not what I was doing
at least I contend that's not what I was
doing because that's what he heard he
goes oh I know this one I've heard this
before yeah and and you haven't read my
book it didn't seem to occur to him that
say it is possible Mr Hitchens to read
your book and yet still after having
done so disagree with you yeah it's
sometimes when you hear people speak
especially guys that are a little bit
older I think there is a there is kind
of like reverse agism that goes on which
is who is this sort of young whipper
snapper person who I maybe have heard of
or haven't heard of much and um almost
like a Blas kind of discrediting of the
thing it's like this is and this is your
show but it's my show so to speak and um
yeah it was like I thought his attitude
was pompous and unlikable and uh my
favorite part was when he threw the
pillow at the microphone throwing the
pillow down and and he kept sort of
walking back over he says he says you
know I I don't want you to post this and
yet obsessed with no opinion about you
before I've decided that I absolutely do
not like you it was it was uh it was
something and a lot of people messaged
me saying hey like uh I'm so sorry that
happened like you know you're doing all
right and I'm thinking sorry sorry I
thought there's no way that this is
happening I mean when it looked like he
was about to get up I thought surely not
but then internally I'm thinking like go
on then do it do it because I don't
think I've done anything wrong here it
was the podcasting equivalent of come on
mate have a go yeah but you know you
know the weirdest thing was because he
he sort of gets up to go and he walks
out and he stands at the door and he's
and it's I wish you kind of could have
seen his body language it was it was
very there's one point where you can see
it when he walks back into shot and he
says something and then after he said it
he just sort of stands there looking at
me as if to say like what have you got a
girl and so he' keep going like I'm
going to go
now I'm
going I'm going to I'm going and waiting
this the podcast playing hard to get
equivalent it must have been something
like that yeah it was like it was like
the person who wants the fight but wants
to look like they didn't initiate the
fight and I don't think it's my fault
I'll leave it up to the to the Judgment
of The Listener or the viewer I don't
think it's my fault that he spent 17
minutes 17 count them 17 entire minutes
stood at the door telling me how much he
personally dislikes me telling me how
much he doesn't want to see me again
I've I've wanted to do that for as long
as I've known you so well we'll see how
we do yeah today uh you're going to try
and convince me of the existence of God
today you managed to convince chat GPT
that's right which means does it mean
that I'm smart than chat GPT if you
convince me more quickly or more slowly
or not at all I don't know um I I I do
know that it it means that well well
chat gbt if it's going to inherit
eternal life I I sort of wonder how
that's going to work in heaven I I don't
know I mean I I don't know this
recursive nightmare for everyone as they
walk around and they've got the chat GPT
logo floating about yeah the interesting
thing about chat GPT is that you you
sort of you can you can essentially
convince it of anything and so I wasn't
quite sure if it was even a very good
video idea because I'm sure I could just
as easily convince it that God doesn't
exist well at least you can be thankful
that it wasn't able to say it had no
opinion of you before but it absolutely
does not like you and then get up and
walk out quite right some people in the
comments did say that at least you know
chat GPT is stuck around until the end
that would be a task in fact that's
another video idea I got chat gbd to
storm out of an
interview even I probably couldn't do
that in other news this episode is
brought to you by element element is a
tasty electrolyte drink mix with
everything that you need and nothing
that you don't don't it's a healthy
alternative to sugary electrolyte drinks
and it is the best way that I have
started my morning every single day for
over 3 years now it contains a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium potassium and magnesium with no
sugar no coloring no artificial
ingredients or any other junk your
adenosine system that caffeine acts on
isn't active for the first 90 minutes of
the day but your adrenal system is and
salt acts on your adrenal system so if
you want to be more awake want to
regulate your appetite curb cravings and
have better brain health this is the way
to start your day head to drink LM
nt.com
wisdom to get a free sample pack of all
eight flavors with your first box plus
there is a no BS no questions asked
refund policy so you can buy it 100%
risk-free that's drink LM nt.com
slod wisdom thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that clip with
Alex you will love the full length
podcast episode which you can watch
right here go
on give it a tap